بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لليوم الثام والس
يواصل الاحتلال الصهيوني حرب الاباده
النازيه الجماعيه ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه بدعم سياسي ومالي وعسكري امريكي
وبصمت وتخاذل وتقاعس
دولي لا يجرؤ على الحراك الجاد لوقف هذه
الجريمه ضد
شعبنا لقد ارتقى حتى الساعه 21 الف او
يزيد من
الشهداء وجرح واصيب ما يزيد على 56 الفا
اغلبهم من النساء
والاطفال اننا اذ نترحم على الشهداء من
ابناء شعبنا الابرار واذ نسال الله الشفاء
العاجل للجرحى والحريه للاسرى
والمعتقلين فاننا نؤكد ان كل معاني
البطوله والتضحيه والفداء عبر تاريخ
البشريه تقف اليوم عاجزه عن وصف الملحمه
البطوليه التي يخوضها شعبنا وافاء شعبنا
حقه في هذه الملحمه ان شعبنا اليوم يصنع
ملحمه بطوله في قطاع غزه قل نظيرها ليس في
تاريخ فلسطين والمنطقه وحسب وانما في
تاريخ البشريه منذ ان كتب هذا
التاريخ لقد اكد شعبنا
ببطولته انه لا يعرف الانكسار ولا
الاستسلام واكد انه مصمم على انتزاع حريته
واستقلاله وتحقيق الانتصار في هذه المعركه
لقد فشل الاحتلال النازي في تحقيق اي من
اهدافه العدوانيه على ارض
غزه فما يتحدث عنه ثلاثي الاجرام النازي
من انجازات في هذه الحرب لهم ولجيش م
المهزوم ما هي الا ممارسات ارهاب وقتل
ومجازر ضد المدنيين والاطفال والنساء
وتدمير لمقومات الحياه
كافه ابدا حديثي في موضوع الاسرى وتبادل
الاسرى فكثير من الكلام يدور في الاعلام
هذه
الايام اننا نجدد هنا التاكيد انه لا
تفاوض بخصوص اسرى الاحتلال الا بعد وقف
العدوان فاذا اراد هذا العدو وداعموه
اسراهم لدى المقاومه احياء فعليهم ان
يوقفوا عدوانهم الاجرامي على قطاع غزه وان
قياده الحركه تسعى بكل قوه وتصميم لوقف
العدوان والمجازر على شعبنا بشكل
كامل وليس وقفا مؤقتا فشعبنا يريد وقف
العدوان ولا ينتظر تهدئه
عرف منهم ثلاثه
اسماء هذه هي اسمائهم
اميرام اسرائيل كوبر حييم جرشون بيري يرام
اتاك
مجرر هؤلاء ظهروا قبل ايام في شريط فيديو
وزعه مجاهدون في الاعلام
العسكري هاهم
يتحدثون
[موسيقى]
ين
لما انهم متروكون هنا لان نتنياهو يريد
ذلك وهو وحده من عليه ان يقدم الاجابه
هؤلاء الثلاثه هم من الخمسه الذين انقطع
اتصالنا بالمجموعه المشرفه عليهم ويرجح
لدى قياده القسام انهم قد لقوا
حتفهم انني هنا اقول وبكل وضوح لعائلات
هؤلاء الاسرى ان عليكم ان تقرروا ان يكون
مصير ابنائكم كهؤلاء
الذين قتلوا او كه هؤلاء الذين خرجوا
وعادوا احياء او ان يكون مصير هؤلاء
الابداء كرون اراد الذي لا يعرف له ارض
ولا مكان نحن في قياده الحركه قرارنا ان
نستعيد ابنائنا الاسرى وان نعيد اليكم
ابناءكم بعد ذلك لكن عليكم ان توجهوا هذا
السؤال لنتنياهو هل يريد ذلك ام انه
يريدهم قتل وصرعه ام انه يفضل وصفه رون
اراد في المسار الميداني نؤكد ان تهديدات
ثلاثي الحرب الفاشل بالقضاء على المقاومه
في فلسطين وفي غزه تحديدا وحركه حماس
وكتائب القسام المضفره انما هي تهديدات
فارغه لا تعبر الا عن افلاس ورعب مما يمكن
ان يقع في قابل
الايام لقد انهارت استراتيجيه هزيمه حماس
انهيارا كاملا وهي تلقى فشلا بعد فشل وان
حماس اليوم وكتائبه المضفره هي اقدر في
الميدان مما كانت عليه من جمله الجنود
الذين اعترف الاحتلال بقتلهم منذ ان بدات
العمليه البريه نصفهم قتل قبل الهدنه
المؤقته وما يزيد عن النصف قليلا قتل بعد
هذه الهدنه في مؤشر واضح لقدره القسام في
الاشتباك بعد الهدنه وبعد ان استعر
العدوان ان نتنياهو وحكومته النازيه
عالقون في حرب بلا افق وجيشهم المهزوم
يتكبدوا خسائر فادحه ويغرق اكثر فاكثر في
رمال غزه العزه لقد اراد نتنياهو واهما
انهاء حماس وها هي نهايته ونهايه حكومته
صارت قاب قوسين او ادنى لقد اراد جيشهم ان
يقضي على المقاومه فكانت النتيجه فرار
ضباط هذا الجيش من الميدان وما سحب لواء
جولاني الا هو نوع من الفرار من مصير
محتوم هو الموت او الاعاقه او المصحات
النفسيه بعد ان خسر هذا اللواء ربع قواته
صرعا
وجرحا وان ان ادعاءات الاحتلال بالسيطره
على مناطق واحياء في قطاع غزه يكذبها ويسخ
فها وينصفها استمرار المقاومه في هذه
المناطق وما تكبده لجيش الاحتلال من خسائر
فادحه في جنوده وضباطه وعتاده ولعل تسريح
الالاف من جنود الاحتياط يكشف جزءا من هذه
الحقيقه التي تخفيها حكومه الرؤوس الثلاثه
حكومه الحرب بالنازيه في الكيان
الصهيوني فيما يتعلق بقرار مجلس الامن
الدولي
2720 ان القرار الذي صدر يوم امس الجمعه
الموافق
22 من كانون الاول عام
2023 عن مجلس الامن الدولي والذي يدعو الى
توسيع دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع
غزه
ومراقبتها هو قرار هزيل وخطوه
غير كافيه ولا تلبي متطلبات الحاله
الكارثيه التي صنعتها اله الارهاب
الصهيوني في قطاع غزه فالقرار لم يتضمن
دعوه لوقف العدوان ولا انهاء
الحرب حرب الاباده الجماعيه على شعبنا في
قطاع غزه ان الاداره الامريكيه بسلوكها لا
تزال تؤكد انغماسها ومشاركتها الكامله في
العدوان على شعبنا الفلسطيني لقد عملت هذه
الاداره على مدى خمسه ايام قبل صدور
القرار جاهده لتفريغ هذا القرار من جوهره
ومضمونه الحقيقي واخراجه بهذه الصيغه
الهزيله التي تمكن العدو من استمرار
مجازره وحرب ابادته النازيه ضد شعبنا ان
من واجب مجلس الامن الزام الاحتلال بادخال
المساعدات بكميات كافيه وليس جداء هذا
العدو ان ان واجبات مجلس الامن ادخال هذه
المساعدات الى كل مناطق غزه وليس الخضوع ل
خارطه العدو خصوصا في مناطق شمال القطاع
وتامين الممرات الامنه لادخال كل
المساعدات
الطبيه والاغاثه
والانسانيه اضافه الى الوقود والغاز من كل
المعابر وتحذير الاحتلال من الاستهداف
والتعرض لقوافل الاغاثه والمساعدات
وسيارات الاسعاف والطواقم الصحيه اننا في
حركه حماس نثمن مواقف الدول العربيه التي
طرحت مشروع القرار وسعت لتحسين صياغته كما
نثمن الموقف المسؤول من الوفد الروسي الذي
حاول ادخال تعديلات جاده على مشروع القرار
تساهم في وضع حد لهذا العدوان النازي على
شعبنا غير ان هذه المحاوله قد اصطدمت
بالموقف الامر
الذي لا يزال شريكا في هذه الجريمه وفي
هذا
الارهاب هذا ينقلنا للحديث عن المعاناه
الانسانيه لشعبنا واهلنا لقد خلفت هذه
الحرب
النازيه والعدوان على قطاع غزه منذ ان بدا
هذا العدوان مليون و800 الف من النازحين
اما في مراكز النزوح او الايواء او في
منازل ومساكن اخرى وقرابه مليون و300 ال
هم مجموع سكان قطاع غزه يعيشون اليوم
ظروفا انسانيه بالغه الخطوره وغير مسبوقه
من المعاناه والماساه الحقيقيه بفعل
الاباده الجماعيه والتجويع والتعطيش
ويمنع عنهم الاحتلال النازي الغذاء والماء
والدواء فمن لم يرتقي منهم شهيدا بالقصف
ارتقى مرضا وجوعا وعطشا بل ان الجرحى ايضا
يلاحقهم الموت حتى في المستشفيات والاطفال
على وجه الخصوص وهذه قصه دنيا ابو محسن
التي نقول من خلالها للعالم ان شهدائنا
وجرحانا ليسوا ارقام بل هم بشر لهم الام
وامال وطموحات هذه دنيا ابو محسن قتل
اهلها جميعا في قصف صهيوني لبيت عائلتها
لم يبقى من العائله سواها وبترت قدم في
هذا القص وانتقلت الى المستشفى هذه قدمها
المبتوره انتقلت الى المستشفى وهي تتماثل
للشفاء قصف المستشفى بقذيفه اخترقت الجدار
وسقطت عليها دون ان تنفجر فادت الى
استشهادها هذه هي القذيفه التي سقطت على
الشهيده دنيا ابو محسن واسمعوا لها وهي
رغم الالم والجراح كيف تتحدث بامل بالغ في
المستقبل انا دن
محسن
اهلي
رجي وحمي ان اطلع دكتوره اعالج الاف اعالج
[موسيقى]
اطف هذه صوره لمعاناه هذا الشعب راره في
نفس الوقت ان يكمل مشوار الحياه قدما الى
امام يتخطى الصعاب وحرب الاباده النازيه
والارهاب ليصنع مستقبلا رغم ان في
الاحتلال سيكون باذن الله مستقبلا زاهرا
مشرقا منتصرا محررا لكل فلسطين وعاصمتها
القدس هذا يقودني الحديث حول معاناه
القطاع الصحي في قطاع غزه في حرب الاحتلال
على مستشفيات دمرت اكثر من 110 سيارات
اسعاف وارتقى 320 شهيدا من الاطباء
والكوادر الطبيه والمسعفين ورجال
الانقاذ واستهدفت بالتدمير والقصف
10045 مؤسسه صحيه فيما خرج بشكل كامل من
الخدمه 25 مستشفى عدا عن مئات الجرحى
الذين يفقدون او يفارقون الحياه نتيجه عدم
توفر الخدمات الصحيه فيما بقي من
المستشفيات لنقص في الدواء بل وحتى في
المخدر الذي يمكن ان تجرى العمليات
الجراحيه من خلاله في هذا السياق نؤكد ما
يلي ان هذه الحرب النازيه بجرائمها
ومجازرها ستبقى راسخه في ذاكره شعبنا
راسخه بقصه بطوله وانتصار لشعب فلسطين
وراسخ بحكايه فضيحه لحقيقه الاحتلال
النازي الصهيوني وحربه لاستئصال شعبنا
ولاصقه ايضا وراسخ بانها وصمه عار على
جبين مرتكبيها والداعمين لها
والمتقاعدات وتجريمها ووقفها فضلا عن
محاكمه منفذيها كمجرم حرب ان مؤسسات الامم
المتحده ووكاله الانرو ومنظمه الصحه الع
العالميه تتحمل المسؤوليه عن استمرار هذه
المعاناه والماساه بوقوفها عاجزه عن اداء
دورها فنحن لا نطلب منها اكثر من ان تقوم
بدورها الاغاثي والصحي والانساني بدل ان
ترضخ لشروط الاحتلال
وضغوطه واذ اتضحت حقيقه الكذب الصهيوني
والجريمه الصهيونيه
لدرجه لدرجه بالغه دف عت كثيرا من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه والغربيه لكشف هذه
الاكاذيب حول استخدام المستشفيات كمقرات
عسكريه او قياديه فاننا ندعو كل دول
العالم وكل المنظمات الحقوقيه الى اتخاذ
موقف دولي واضح وحاسم من جرائم الاحتلال
بحق المستشفيات والكوادر الطبيه من تدمير
وتخريب ممنهج
واعتقال للاطباء بائ وللك وادر الطبيه
وقتلهم وضروره محاسبه كل الذين ينتهكون
القانون الدولي الانسانيه على جرائمهم كما
ندعو دولنا العربيه والاسلاميه الشقيقه
الى تسيير قوافل ووفود رسميه وشعبيه
لادخال كل المواد الاغاثه والطبيه والوقود
والغاز الى قطاع غزه شمالا وجنوبا واخراج
الجرحى والمصابين للعلاج في خارج القطاع
ونذكر قاده العرب
والمسلمين وفي ظل القرار الدولي انهم قد
اتخذوا قرارا سابقا بالادخال العاجل
للاغاثه الى قطاع غزه ولازال شعبنا ينتظر
تنفيذ هذا القرار كما ندعو كل المنظمات
الاغاثه والصحيه في العالم الى الدخول
لقطاع غزه والوقوف على حجم الكارثه
الانسانيه في القطاع ونؤكد هنا ضروره
ادخال المستشفيات الميدانيه في كافه
التخصصات الطبيه الى كل انحاء قطاع
غزه ونؤكد على دور الامم المتحده ووكاله
الاونروا في حمايه مراكز الايواء وحمايه
النازحين واغاثه في المدارس وندعو الى
توفير الحمايه للمؤسسات الطبيه والعاملين
فيها من اطباء وكادر طبي كما نؤكد ضروره
اتخاذ موقف دولي واضح من جرائم الاحتلال
بحق المستشفيات والكوادر الطبيه
وضروره محاسبه كل الذين ينتهكون القانون
الدولي لهذه
الجرائم ان مجازر الاباده الجماعيه التي
يرتكبها جيش الاحتلال النازي من اعدامات
ميدانيه طالت عده عوائل من قطاع غزه والتي
تعد عائله عنان في مدينه غزه اخر مثال
واضح لها من اعدامات مروعه ينفذها هذا
الجيش النازي ضد ابناء غزه اذ كشفت
تفاصيلها بعد انسحاب الجيش من غزه حيث
وجدت العائله باكملها وقد جرى اعدام
افرادها بالرصاص داخل المنزل رجالا ونساء
واطفال كما نقل عن عائلات اخرى اعدام
الرجال امام النساء والاطفال الذين تركوا
كشهود على هذه الجريمه الوحشيه
والساديه لقد ارتكب الاحتلال الناز كذلك
جرائم مروعه بحق النساء الحوامل والمدنيين
العزل في محيط المستشفيات بعد اعدامهم بدم
بارد وتجريف جثامين هن باليات وجرافات
والعبث بقبور الشهداء واخراج اجسادهم
الطاهره في مشاهد وحشيه تثبت للعالم انه
عصابه مجرمه فاشيه متجرده من كل قيم
الانسان
ونؤكد هنا ضروره ملاحقه ما يتعرض له اكثر
من 8000 معتقل في سجون الاحتلال ومعسكرات
من تعذيب ممنهج وسوء معامله واخفاء قصري
وقتل متعمد وفق الشهادات والاعدام بدم
بارد اننا في ضوء هذه الجرائم الوحشيه
والاعدامات الممنهجه بحق الاهالي والاسرى
والمعتقلين ندعو كل المؤسسات الحق قيه
والانسانيه الى التدخل الفوري للاطلاع على
اوضاع المعتقلين والاسرى في سجون الاحتلال
وتشكيل فرق دوليه للتحقيق في هذه الجرائم
من قتل واعدام ميداني للاهالي والعائلات
وفي السجون وتوثيق هذه الجرائم كخطوه اولى
لمحاكمه مجرمي الحرب النازيه الصهيونيه
فضلا عن وقف هذه الجريمه واستمرارها ونؤكد
مجد دا اننا ونحن نتحدث عن هذا الارهاب
النازي الصهيوني فانه لن يكسر اراده شعبنا
وصموده ومقاومته ولن يفلح في تحقيق اي من
اهدافه العدوانيه باذن الله وسيبقى شعبنا
صامدا راسخا ثابتا مدافعا عن ارضه
ومقدساته وسيرحل الغزاه شذاذ الافاق الذين
جاؤوا من كل مكان عن ارضنا فنحن اصحاب
الارض الباقون المنزرع فيها الضاربه
جذورنا فيها ابعد مما يظن كثيرون اما
الاحتلال فهو الى زوال قريب باذن الله
الرحمه للشهداء شهداء شعبنا ومقاومتنا وكل
الشهداء على طريق القدس على طريق تحرير
القدس والشفاء العاجل للجرحى والحريه
للاسرى والمعتقلين والمجد والنصر لشعبنا
ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد
والسلام عليكم رحمه الله وبكاته